alte liebe rostet vielleicht doch in der
spd wird um eine haltung zu russland
gerungen was auch eine haltung zum putin
einschließt der druck ist immens die
sozialdemokratische ost politik der
letzten jahrzehnte zu korrigieren
nicht nur ein schröder problem die spd
und russland jetzt in der phoenix runde
[Musik]
phoenix runde
herzlich willkommen bei uns meine gäste
zunächst zugeschaltet klaus von dohnanyi
von der spd
früherer erster bürgermeister der freien
und hansestadt hamburg und auch
ehemalige minister in den
bundesregierungen von willy brandt und
helmut schmidt und buch autor eines
buches mit dem titel nationale
interessen am anfang des jahres in
schienen gibt es geht dabei um die
europäische und die deutsche
souveränität
angesichts globaler veränderungen die
aktualität dieses buches kann fast nicht
übertroffen werden aufgrund der neusten
entwicklungen ruprecht polenz ist bei
uns von der cdu ehemaliger
generalsekretär der partei und
langjähriger vorsitzender des
auswärtigen ausschusses des deutschen
bundestages hier im studio helene
borowski
hauptstadtkorrespondent in der
frankfurter allgemeinen zeitung und
frank stauss ist bei uns
politikwissenschaftler angelo politik
und kommunikationsberater und sie haben
viele wahlkämpfe für die spd gemanagt
und begleitet herr von dohnanyi steht
die spd vor einem scherbenhaufen ihrer
ostpolitik
nein das glaube ich nicht ich glaube die
spd hat in der vergangenheit eine
vernünftige politik gegenüber russland
gemacht mit dem versuch immer auch
frieden zu halten aber zugleich auch
dafür zu sorgen dass man natürlich auch
verteidigungs fähig ist dass das nicht
so funktioniert hat mit der verteidigung
wie das vielleicht hätte sein sollen das
ist aber nicht alleine die schuld der
spd-frau bobrowski manchmal erscheint es
ja als ließe sich für die spd das
problem russland auf die
personenschützer zu reduzieren ja das
halte ich für zu kurz gesprungen und das
ist auch so schröder ist die spitze des
eisbergs eines phänomens das ja weit in
die spd hinein reicht die diskussion
haben wir den vergangenen wochen gehabt
über die rolle von frank walter
steinmeier insbesondere als
außenminister sind die zitate wieder
hochgekommen etwa 2008 nach dem
einmarsch russlands nach georgien wo er
schon kurz darauf sagte man dürfe jetzt
nicht die nerven verlieren sondern müsse
auch sehen dass man schnell wieder zur
partnerschaftlichen beziehungen
zurückkommt seine aussagen über das
säbelrasseln
wohlgemerkt der nato darüber dass sich
sozusagen russland und die legitimen
sicherheitsinteressen wie es dann immer
so heißt das also viel verständnis für
russland viel sympathie nicht nur bei
steinmeier sondern gibt es ja etliche
andere das war erreicht wie gesagt weit
in die spd hinein ich darf daran
erinnern dass wenige wochen vor
kriegsbeginn noch im februar
der generalsekretär kevin kühnert davor
warnte konflikte in der ukraine
herbeizureden also das zeigt natürlich
ja auf welchem das was für was von was
die prämissen viele in der spd
ausgegangen sind entgegen der
zahlreichen warnungen die es gab ja
insbesondere von unseren östlichen
nachbarn und jetzt ist da glaube ich ein
aufarbeitungsprozess angesagt in der
gesamten partei der nicht nur damit
begründet werden kann dass man sich in
russland getäuscht habe weil es
tatsächlich genügend anhaltspunkte gab
und er auch nicht damit erledigt sein
kann mit schröder ihn gegebenenfalls
auszuschließen oder etwas anderes mit
ihm zu machen herr problems auch gegen
die union werden ja vorwürfe lauter
russland zu wohlwollend behandelt zu
haben waren denn für die einstige
kanzler oder kanzlerin partei cdu lange
zeit gute handelsbeziehungen wichtiger
als ein kritischer blick auf einen
gefährlichen autokraten
also sicherheit auch die cdu
große fehler zum teil gemacht ich denke
vor allen dingen an die entscheidung
nach der annexion der film 2014 und den
militärischen angriffen gegen den don
was in der ukraine hat man noch
zugestimmt und nord stream 2 auf den weg
gebracht das war eigentlich ein völlig
falsches signal und es gibt sicherlich
weil man sich das jetzt genauer anschaut
auch noch den einen oder anderen punkt
ich bin deshalb sehr dafür dass man die
russlandpolitik die seit 1990 das
scheint mir der richtige zeitpunkt zu
sein nach dem ende des kalten krieges in
einer enquete kommission des deutschen
bundestags untersucht das hat den
vorteil
es geht über einen längeren zeitraum
diese oppositions regierungsgeschichte
nivelliert sich ein bisschen vor allem
auch dadurch dass wir externe experten
dabei haben könnte soweit ich sehe
gewinnt dieser gedanke etwas an
unterstützung ich glaube das braucht die
deutsche politik um zu sehen welche
weichen worden war falsch gestellt und
von wem der staat die größte
verantwortung für die jetzige
kanzlerpartei die spd direkt olaf scholz
kommuniziert er eigentlich überzeugend
in der frage wie jetzt umgehen mit
russland russland das ja gerade so ein
nachbarland in schutt und asche legt
olaf scholz ist wie wir alle auch schon
wussten bevor er kanzler wurde ein
kein sehr
intensiv reden der mensch
sondern einer der
über über darüber wasser spricht und wie
er spricht und was er wann sagt lässt
sich da auch nicht unter druck setzen
aber eines ist sicherlich richtig und da
möchte ich vielleicht mal noch mal ganz
kurz darauf zu kommen und das finde ich
auch für sehr sehr gut was er polens
gerade gesagt hat wir reden ja hier über
eine nationale wirtschafts energie
sicherheits außenpolitik der letzten 40
jahre
zu der die spd natürlich einen beitrag
geleistet hat aber beim besten willen
nicht den entscheidenden
ausschließlichen dazu gehören auch noch
andere und ich glaube es ist wirklich
wenig hilfreich sich jetzt irgendwelche
zitate auszugraben wer wann wo was
gesagt hat und das war sehr
ministerpräsident von bayern söder heute
gesagt hat indem er ja sowohl frau
merkel als auch ein steinmeier in schutz
genommen hat vor angriffen zu sagen es
war ja der versuch
frieden zu schaffen und frieden zu
bewahren
dieser versuch ist gescheitert das
wissen wir heute alle aber der versuch
war ja viele mühen wert ich denke olaf
scholz kann einige dinge klarer
formulieren also das heute tut aber
er ist auch ein sehr besonnener
politiker und ich habe schon das gefühl
dass viele menschen im land gerade
sehr froh sind dass jemand im kanzleramt
sitzt der besonnen handelt und der auch
überlegt handelt und der auch nicht auf
jeden druck der medial entsteht sofort
reagiert dass angela merkel über
übrigens auch nicht getan und ich glaube
das ist ein stil an dem wir uns alle
gewöhnen müssen ich glaube er wird
dieses ziel auch überarbeiten und
durchaus auch verbessern aber wir können
nicht erwarten dass er sich grundlegend
ändern wird er von dohnanyi jetzt muss
ich die spd ja dem vorwurf wehren bei
ihr gebe es besonders viele putin
verstehe es gibt ja nicht nur eine
sozialdemokratische identität mit dieser
tradition beladenen entspannungs politik
die willy brandt mit auch für die brand
zurück geht es gibt da auch
wirtschaftliche verflechtungen die der
spd vorgeworfen werden bis hin zur
politischen kampagne wir kommen ja auch
gleich noch mal auf gerhard schröder zu
sprechen was sagen sie da was kann man
da entgegnen hat die spd die situation
mit russland gewisser weise auch falsch
eingeschätzt
also ich glaube ich möchtest du nicht
noch einmal auf einen polens antworten
weil es ja klar ist dass ausgerechnet
frau merkel die ich hier in schutz
nehmen möchte nach der krim aktion im
jahr 2014 nachweislich die stärksten
sanktionen von allen westlichen ländern
verlangt hat also es ist nicht so
gewesen dass die bundesregierung in
dieser zeit etwa nachgiebig war zweitens
möchte ich auch noch mal ausdrücklich
unterstreichen das ist natürlich olaf
scholz und das sage ich zum frau pro
roski oder scholz hat ja seinen eid auf
die bundesrepublik deutschland geleistet
und er hat nicht einen alt auf die
vereinigten staaten geleistet oder auf
kohlen oder auch auf die ukraine wir
sind verantwortlich für deutschland und
olaf scholz hat versucht zu sehen welche
folgen eventuell mit welchen schritten
vor kunden sein könnten er ist
verantwortlich für deutschland er ist
nicht verantwortlich für die ukraine er
hat auch nicht von der ukraine
nachrichten bekommen als diese
leichtfertiger weise im jahr 2019
ausgerechnet die nato mitgliedschaft der
ukraine in die verfassung der ukraine
geschrieben das hat uns niemand
mitgeteilt das haben wir nur aus der
zeitung erfahren also ich will
ausdrücklich darauf hinweisen dass die
politik die die bundesregierung und die
auch die spd in der vergangenheit
gemacht hat eine politik der vorsicht
eine politik des friedens und eine
politik zugleich auch der wehrhaftigkeit
war schließlich war es helmut schmidt
und kein anderer der der nato
doppelbeschluss zum ersten mal ins
gespräch brachte durch seinen vortrag
ich glaube eben
1979 bei dem institut für statistik
studies in london also der spd
pazifismus vorzuwerfen oder etwas
aufarbeiten zu müssen
aus der vergangenheit der spd das halte
ich für glatten unsinn und ich wehre
mich auch dagegen und ich möchte
sicherstellen dass in der öffentlichen
debatte jetzt klar gemacht wird wo für
eine politik und ein bundeskanzler
verantwortlich ist und dass helmut kohl
in seinen gesprächen mit gorbatschow
dann voll auf die linie von willy brandt
und helmut schmidt eingestiegen ist das
doch ein zeichen dass das zu erfolg
führen kann also ich bin nicht der
meinung dass wir etwas aufzuarbeiten
haben wir müssen im gegenteil
friedenspolitik in der zukunft
fortsetzen
jetzt gibt es abholen es ja auch
vorwürfe osteuropäischer nato-partner
baltischen staaten und polen wir hätten
im laufe der zeit einfach ihre
sicherheitsbedürfnisse auch ihre distanz
dieses russland haben auch aus
historischen gründen und es zeigt sich
ja wie begründet auch diese befürchtung
war zu wenig ernst genommen nord stream
2 ist das klassische beispiel da hat
deutschland mit russland einen deal
gemacht nicht nur ging die pipeline an
diesen ländern vorbei sondern ganze
politische entscheidungsfindung ging an
diesen ländern vorbei war das ein fehler
da sozusagen polen und den baltischen
staaten das gefühl zu geben also
eigentlich habt ihr hier nichts zu
melden das machen wir mit russland
gemeinsam das betrifft ja die alte
koalition aus union und spd
sind das war mit sicherheit ein fehler
und das war übrigens einer der fehler
der rot-grünen koalition von 1998 bis
2005 den merkel versucht hat zu
korrigieren sie ist eigentlich bei ihren
flügen nach moskau immer entweder auf
dem hin- und rückflug auch in warschau
gewesen beispielsweise um diesen
eindruck russland und deutschland
verständigten sich über die köpfe
unserer nachbarn die nachbarn sind
nämlich polen und die baltischen staaten
und nicht russland über die köpfe der
nachbarn hinweg und da gibt es in der
tat natürlich über den
tropf wirtschaft also hinter stalin pakt
ein tiefsitzendes trauma was deutsche
außenpolitik immer beachten muss und wir
müssen jetzt natürlich schon herr von
dohnanyi einräumen dass die warnungen
wir würden russland verkennen wir würden
putin verkennen die aus den baltischen
staaten auch von polen insbesondere
gekommen sind dass die erstens
berechtigt waren und wir müssen uns
zweitens fragen warum haben wir das denn
verkannt und ich glaube ein punkt ist
dass wir
im kalten krieg in einer harten
konfrontation mit der sowjetunion waren
dann war der kalte krieg zu ende
wir bekamen die wiedervereinigung auch
mit der zustimmung des hätten wir ja
nicht gekriegt der sowjetunion und
gorbatschow ver einer der beliebtesten
politiker in deutschland und daraus
entstand das gefühl dass jetzt
gorbatschow hat auch vom gemeinsamen
europäischen haus gesprochen dass jetzt
praktisch
hier mit einem ganz anderen russland zu
tun hätten als es früher die sowjetunion
war und dann haben wir einfach
angefangen waren signale zu übersehen
dass eben putin weder gorbatschows noch
rechnet im übrigen ist er hat im inneren
angefangen
repressiv zu an ihren die presse dem
kreml zu unterwerfen
oppositionsstimmen ausgeschaltet
oppositionelle ermorden lassen et cetera
das hier alles übersehen obwohl
er ja aus der geschichte wissen dass
repression nach innen über kurz oder
lang in aggression nach außen um
schlecht und dann gab es die signale die
brutalität des tschetschenien-krieges es
gab das signal der georgien invasion es
gab die annexion der krim es gab den
bass und es ist sicherlich richtig dass
merkel da die damals herz ist möglich
eine sanktion in der eu wahrscheinlich
durchgesetzt hat ja aber wir wissen ja
heute sie hätten doppelt so hart
ausfallen müssen denn die addition der
kreml hatte die charta von paris
verletzt auf der die europäische
friedensordnung nachdem helsinki prozess
aufgebaut war denn auch die sowjetunion
unterschrieben hatte souveränität keine
gewalt und so weiter und so weiter
und da waren die signale die dann nach
russland ging
nicht nicht ausreichend um zu vermeiden
was wir jetzt erleben und austrian 1 war
ein großer fehler weil er mut den die
möglichkeit gegeben hat und das war auch
der einzige zweck dieser pipeline die
ukraine strategisch unter druck setzen
zu können was er so lange nicht hätte
tun können solange auch seine west
bundes also in westeuropa das gas aus
russland auf dessen einnahmen putin
angewiesen war nur über die ukraine
beziehen von für die ukraine sollte
sozusagen umschifft blatt mit einem mit
einer bypass pipeline und das war von
anfang an ein großes strategisches dann
haben wir jetzt war die was sich seit
1990 in europa ereignet hat es geht ja
um die frage spd und russland klaus von
dohnanyi hat er gesagt es gebe für die
spd nicht auf genau ich wollte aufhören
dohnanyi an auch weil er mich direkt
angesprochen hat ich glaube man muss
wirklich drei
zeitabschnitte unterscheiden der eine
ist vor 1990 und ich glaube da sollten
wir jetzt vielleicht nicht in die
aufarbeitung der glaube das muss man
wirklich abtrennen weil das eine andere
zeit ist kalter krieg aber anfangen wenn
man den zeitraum ab 1990
bis zum kriegsausbruch betrachtet hat
glaube ich herr polenz alles richtige
gesagt dass ich jetzt hier nicht noch
mal wiederholen will aber die frage ist
schon und da meine ich schon herr von
dohnanyi dass eine aufarbeitung nicht
nur der spd auch bei der cdu insgesamt
es kann auch im journalismus sein und
gesellschaftlich absolut notwendig ist
weil man sich doch fragen muss wie kann
es denn sein dass man all diese dinge
die doch bekannt waren also herr polenz
hat gesagt eben auch diese gezielten
tötung von oppositionellen im land
außerhalb des landes die verbreitung von
verschwörungstheorien und und vieles
mehr was ja auch in deutschland
tatsächlich wir sind uns ja die sagt was
h gefahren bewusst also cyberangriffe
und so weiter und trotzdem haben viele
noch gedacht wir haben es zu tun mit dem
putin von 2001 der irgendwie von einer
kooperation zwischen russland und der
nato gesprochen hat eine vollkommene
verklärung dieses mannes an nicht sehen
wollen der der radikalisierung auch der
dass da eine diktatur entstanden ist
mittlerweile und wir tun so als könnten
wir mit dem einfach so weiter
kooperieren und im übrigen sind ist es
ja auch gegen die interessen
deutschlands gewesen was wir jetzt sehen
mit der energieabhängigkeit wir uns mit
diesem ein land und auch da gab es viele
warnungen von außen europäern aber auch
von anderen das ist so und dann ist
abzugrenzen davon glaube ich noch mal
die zeit von heute und herr von dohnanyi
da haben sie ja was richtiges gesagt der
amtszeit den die minister und auch der
bundeskanzler geschworen haben das habe
ich jetzt von anderen auch schon gehört
dass sie sozusagen gesagt haben ja mit
dem kriegsausbruch haben wir uns erst
mal sind wir uns bewusst geworden was
dieser amtszeit bedeutet nämlich schaden
vom deutschen volk abzuwenden also und
dass das auch das etui grün sind besser
darin herrscht ausgesagt als der kanzler
das zu kommunizieren die ja auch robert
habeck ist ja gut daran diese zweifel
deutlich zu machen diese innere
zerrissenheit wie schwer es ihm fällt
nicht alles zu tun was möglich ist weil
es eben möglicherweise zu einer weiteren
eskalation führen kann die dann schaden
für das deutsche volk bedeuten würde und
ich glaube das ist ein da gebe ich ihnen
recht da muss man und da bin ich auch
dankbar für einen besonderen kanzler
auch wenn ich mir wünschen würde dass er
klarer kommunizieren würde und dass man
nicht immer nur das gefühl hat er macht
die dinge erst dann wenn sie wirklich
gar nicht anders gehen also er wirkt ja
schon wie ein getriebener
aber trotzdem bin ich auch nicht eine
die die da meint dass man heute
trotz obwohl es hat es schwierig ist
angesichts der schrecklichen bilder aus
der ukraine aber dass man da auch
tatsächlich besonnenheit das wort der
stunde ist war ja das was wir erlebt
haben die letzten jahr nicht unbedingt
eine wahnhafte entwicklung einen kleinen
moment hätte eine zwanghafte entwicklung
sondern es gab ja ganz konkrete vorfälle
die sind jetzt auch gerade schon
angeklungen der tiergarten mord die
vergiftung von script von die ermordung
von boris nemzow von frau politkowskaja
die die vergiftung auch von der ball nie
das war ja der bekannteste fall
eigentlich dazu ist hier es gab zwar
proteste aber so von offizieller seite
relativ wenig passiert egal jetzt wer
bundeskanzler war der außenminister war
die kamen ja aus union und aus
spd-mann das zuviel diplomatischen
rücksichten können sie sich erklären was
da in den köpfen vorgegangen ist dass
man da nicht so reagiert hat wie man
vielleicht heute reagieren würde und
heute sagt ja auch jeder das war eine
sache die oder das waren mordanschläge
die alle putin befohlen hat ich bin
natürlich weiter man muss allerdings
sehen die man geht eigentlich über den
politischen gesprächen ausgeschlagen
eigentlich gesellschaftlicher konsens
ich würde gerne sagen und das ist
das ist etwas was natürlich auch mit dem
zu tun hat was ja auch schon
angesprochen wurde mit mit auch
wirtschaftlichen abhängigkeiten die man
geschaffen hatte und
gleichzeitig es darin aber auch bequem
gemacht hat und das bei der politik
alleine anzusiedeln ist natürlich
richtig weil politik trägt verantwortung
aber man muss auch sagen es war bis weit
in die wirtschaft und auch in die
gesellschaft konsens dieses feld
eigentlich nicht wirklich anzupacken
dass das ist ein großer fehler ich bin
auch wirklich dabei dass ich wollte
jetzt nur weil der titel der sendung aus
meiner sicht ein wenig einseitig geraten
war noch mal darauf hinweisen das ist
kein alleiniges problem der spd im
gegenteil die spd in den letzten
40 jahren sieben jahre den kanzler
gestellt
das alleine kann es ja nicht gewesen
sein sondern da waren eben viele andere
dabei auch die fdp weil ich bin jetzt
wirklich weit davon entfernt dass er
jetzt gegenseitig finger zeigen die am
klarsten auch im bundestagswahlkampf
muss man ganz klar sagen auch auf der
sicherheitskonferenz in münchen als die
drei kanzlerkandidatin aufeinander
trafen war am klarsten annalena baerbock
ganz ganz eindeutig aber es war weder
dort noch
noch später konsens es war
regierungspolitik in deutschland
überwiegend eventuell der hintergrund
das ist dass dieser vorwurf entstanden
ist lag auch daran dass man der spd
unterstellt sie wird den bayern in
russland oder was die russlandpolitik
jetzt die reaktion auf die ukraine auf
den ukraine überfall einfach zu
vorsichtig sein und zu zurückhaltend und
eigentlich nicht putin klar sagen wo es
lang geht also
das wieder kriegt
eine entwicklung und die entwicklung von
der wir alle dann letztendlich mal bis
hin zu dem amerikanischen
sicherheitsdienste die ja gesagt haben
der angriff wird mehr oder minder an
diesem oder jenem tag beginnen das hat
ja selbst nicht geglänzt gesagt die
werden nicht angreifen sie werden nur in
einer gewissen region bleiben das heißt
das war am ende dann doch in seiner
massivität
zumindest für die politik und nicht nur
in deutschland überraschend aber es
wurden ja dann maßnahmen ergriffen und
sie werden immer weiter ergriffen und
bundeskanzler scholz hat er von anfang
an gesagt er macht das multilaterale
macht das in abstimmung und das was
jetzt passiert ist ist ja auch infolge
einer veränderung der taktik auch in den
usa eben andere waffen zu liefern als in
franken hat er gesagt er macht das in
abstimmung sie sind vorbereitung der
konferenz von rammstein passiert und
dann in ramstein und 100 worden aber
nochmal er lässt sich da im gegenteil
nicht treiben das ist vielleicht ein
eindruck der medial entstehen kann aber
genau das gegenteil ist der fall die
erwägt ab er spricht mit den verbündeten
und spricht natürlich auch mit der
ukraine möglicherweise hat die umfrage
aber nicht so viel zeit hat oder von
dohnanyi
ja es gibt ja eine reihe von
überlegungen die man jetzt anstellen
muss in dem zusammenhang und ich möchte
noch mal zurück greifen zunächst auf die
these von vw golf ski dass man auf das
jahr der das fall der mauer also auf die
wiedervereinigung auf das jahr 1990
zurück kommen ist
wenn man das tut da muss man
unbestreitbar feststellen und das hat
nochmal gorbatschow vor wenigen monaten
noch mal bestätigt das ist natürlich das
was der außenminister der usa der
beecker damals in seinem protokoll
festgehalten hat ergab nämlich eine
zusage die nato nicht über deutschland
hinaus zu erweitern dann gab es zehn
jahre lang eine diskussion über diese
fragen und schließlich gab es eine immer
größere annäherung
der ukraine an die politik der usa und
zwar indem die ukraine sich nicht nur
aufrüsten ließ sondern zugleich auch
feststellen ließ dass die
nato-mitgliedschaft ein essential ein
wesentlicher teil der politik der
ukraine sein müsse und das war der
wirkliche streitpunkt und wenn präsident
beiden dann im jahre
2022 vor wenigen monaten nach der nato
konferenz gesagt hat er habe sanktionen
angedroht aber gewusst dass sie nicht
wirken hat ja wörtlich gesagt sessions
neverdie tor das heißt er hat ein mittel
einen angewandt von dem er wusste dass
er den krieg nicht verhindern würde und
deswegen meine ich man muss beide seiten
betrachten natürlich hat putin den krieg
begonnen natürlich ist er daran schuld
natürlich sein kriegsbeginn immer ein
verbrechen aber dass die zb die ukraine
heute uns vorwirft wir hätten uns zu
abhängig gemacht über den gasbezug aus
russland aber die ukraine selber darauf
immer gedrängt hat dass sie so viel gas
wie irgend möglich durch ihre leitungen
beziehen will das ist doch auch war ich
würde ganz gerne noch mal nach meiner
meinung
wir müssen sehr viel objektiver und sehr
viel und sehr viel nüchterner über die
lage heute
beraten denn wenn wir das nicht tun dann
werden wir immer weiter in richtung
eines großen krieges treiben der krieg
der heute in der ukraine stattfindet ist
ein schaubild für das was in deutschland
stattfinden würde wenn wir den großen
krieg nicht vermeiden und als in roland
scholz deswegen zum beispiel zögert das
olaf scholz vorsichtig ist dass olaf
scholz versucht sozusagen die
friedenspolitik immer auch mit zu
berücksichtigen
das ist doch notwendig und deswegen
braucht die spd überhaupt keine
lehrstunde was sie hätte politisch tun
sollen gut wirklich komme darauf nochmal
zurück aber weil ich jetzt auch
kritisiert hatten es war ein bisschen
einseitig in der titelgebung es ging
darum die spd dass die spd in sachen
russland verhältnis zu russland im
moment besonders im fokus liegt liegt
auch an ihrem früheren bundeskanzler
gerhard schröder dass man das damit
verbindet die spd hat sich zwar auf
breiter front distanziert von ihm hatten
ja auch aufgefordert
die partei zu verlassen die partei nicht
weiter zu schädigen auch durch seine
öffentlichen auftritte bei interviews
zum beispiel wie sollte man mit gerd
schröder denn eigentlich umgehen aus
sicht der spd jetzt wieder diesen
schönen ironischen satz noch nicht mal
ignorieren wäre das das beste ich wollte
noch einen satz sagen damit das nicht so
unwidersprochen stehen bleibt von herrn
von dohnanyi der wieder diese these
aufstellte dass die nato versprochen
habe nicht nach osten zu erweitern das
stimmt so nicht jedenfalls gibt es
mit
welchen wir müssen es nicht
ausdiskutieren ich wollte einfach nur
sagen damit es nicht so zu sagen so
einseitig dargestellt wird ich bin der
meinung das stimmt so nicht jetzt komme
ich auf ihre frage wie geht man mit gerd
schröder um ja ist es schwierig
parteiausschlussverfahren haben wir in
der geschichte gesehen tun eigentlich
selten der partei gut die ausschließen
muss sie führen eher dazu dass derjenige
der ausgeschlossen wird noch mal
sozusagen in den medien ja
sozusagen wir dass diese ganzen
geschichten wieder hochkommen was also
im grunde genommen hat das selten gutes
ende und ist es auch die hürden die
rechtlichen hürden für ein
ausschlussverfahren sind ja sehr sehr
hoch also da hat eigentlich keine partei
bisher sonderlich gute erfahrungen mit
gemacht es gibt aber jetzt von diversen
untergliederungen der spd tatsächlich
anträgen auszuschließen da war ja die
parteiführung zunächst etwas zögerlich
jetzt will sie das wohl doch
unterstützen so ist es gibt ja die
hoffnung in der spd dass gerhard
schröder wir das glaube ich auch bei
hannover 96 und bei der
ehrenmitgliedschaft in hannover und so
weiter gemacht hat dass wenn der druck
so groß wird und wenn er einen ausschuss
befürchten muss es sei dann freiwillig
geht
ob er das dann wirklich tot ist es
glaube ich sehr schwer momentan in
seinen kopf zu schauen er ist ja
jedenfalls in hannover jetzt weitgehend
isoliert auch ansonsten ist er glaube
ich so höre ich das jedenfalls in der
spd weitgehend isoliert zu einer art
persona non grata deren bester freund
jetzt noch wladimir putin zu sein
scheint wobei man ja in dieses
verhältnis auch nicht richtig reingucken
kann also wie viel respekt da
tatsächlich auch vonseiten putins da es
vermag ich überhaupt nicht zu beurteilen
oder ob er einfach sozusagen sich auch
ein bisschen darüber lustig macht dass
dieser mann eigentlich die interessen
seines landes verrät und und so
kooperiert das weiß ich nicht aber es
ist jedenfalls ist natürlich gerhard
schröder und das ist bitter für die spd
dass es weil war der am altkanzler wo
man immer schon auch kritisch drauf
geguckt hat aber wo am ende alle stolz
treffer näher war dabei der vereidigung
von olaf scholz und jetzt ist dieser
teil der geschichte der spd derart
überschattet dass es nicht gilt er einen
film auch als ein erfolgreicher kanzler
herrscht aus wir haben ja für ihn glaube
ich auch gearbeitet können sie sich das
erklären was in ihnen vorgeht macht er
sich vielleicht sogar ein spaß daraus da
als
als beelzebub dazu stehen vor denen über
den alle her ziehen was was treibt ihn
eigentlich an also ich habe lange
aufgegeben mich in das in den kopf von
gehard schröder rhein zu denken weil das
keine sehr freude bringen arbeit ist ich
kann mir das beim besten willen nicht
erklären dass begann aber im prinzip vom
ersten tag als er aus dem amt schied ist
war ja man kann ja damit dass er dass er
wirklich sehr sehr kurz nachdem er aus
dem hand gegangen ist diesen diese
aufgabe übernommen hat also in bezahlten
job gerhard schröder hat einige male
sehr deutlich gemacht dass er das für
ihn im prinzip mit dem ausscheiden aus
dem amt der job sozusagen erledigt ist
er hat also diese diese dass sich an
dieser amtszeit nicht mehr gebunden er
hat letztendlich diese aufgabe nicht
angenommen aus sich heraus dass die
würde des amtes über den eigentlichen
tag
hinausgeht wir haben leider im moment
scheinbar wirklich ein bisschen problem
mit unseren altkanzlern und
mit dem umgang mit dem amt danach ich
glaube wirklich und das kann ich auch
sagen obwohl ich viele wahlkampf gegen
ihn geführt wenn mit kohl war ein guter
kanzler gerhard schröder war ein guter
kanzler beide waren leider lausige
ex-kanzler und das einzig gute was man
dazu sagen kann dass es immer noch
besser als andersrum aber ich habe große
hoffnung dass das frau merkel sind sie
jemals aus den weiten der uckermark
wieder auftaucht dass das besser machen
da habe ich großes vertrauen rainer war
ganz wichtig ist tatsächlich das amt des
bundeskanzlers ist das mit das höchste
wahlamt dass man in der bundesrepublik
bekommen kann vom wähler übertragen
bekommen kann und da endet die
verantwortung nicht an dem tag an dem
man aus dem amt abgewählt wird oder ist
verlässt und das hat gerhard schröder
bis zum heutigen tag aus meiner sicht
nicht verstanden und das schlimme an der
entwicklung ist ja nicht nur dass er
eine falsche politik aus meiner sicht
betreibt sondern dass er damit geld
verdienen das ist ja der knackpunkt an
dieser geschichte und diese distanz die
hätte er wirklich waren sollen aber
jetzt ist einfach hopfen und malz
verloren und mehr als die distanz die
spd jetzt aufgebaut hat geht nicht die
cdu war damals helmut kohl die ähren
würde entzogen die hat gerhard schröder
nicht dass er einzig ist er
ehrenvorsitzender zierung das heißt das
einzige was noch bleibt ist tatsächlich
die mitgliedschaft das wird sich jetzt
versuchen
das einzige an der geschichte wo ich
sagen kann
ist als jemand der viele wahlkämpfe
begleitet tatsächlich ist das den leuten
mehr als die medien mehr als der politik
wirklich herzlich wurscht die meisten
menschen wirklich das kenne ich auch
sehr sehr lange erfahrungen sind
menschen die irgendwann aus dem amt
geschieden sind dann auch mehr oder
minder egal was ihre zustimmung oder
nicht zustimmung zu der politik einer
bestimmten partei in zukunft
angeht das heißt ich glaube nicht dass
die spd da langfristig schaden daraus
ziehen wir so wie die cdu damals ist
auch nicht getan hat aber es bleibt
natürlich wie sie richtig sagen
haben wir bei der überschaubaren anzahl
an sozialdemokratischen kanzler es ist
natürlich tragisch wenn dann einer quasi
aus der geschichte putzen das problem
sind wir auf den aktuell anziehen haben
zurückkommen auf olaf scholz wir haben
jetzt gerade wirklich wichtig das amt
ist und wieder sondern auch richtig
ausfüllt wie beurteilen sie das
verhalten von olaf scholz jetzt gerade
im
ukraine konflikt in dem überfall
russlands auf die ukraine reagiert er
richtig reagierte besonnen klaus von
dohnanyi das ja auch gesagt der wusste
als kanzler ja besonnen reagieren oder
reagiert er zu zurückhaltend und damit
auch verbunden natürlich die frage kann
das auch eine rücksichtnahme seien in
der eigenen partei dass da eben das
verhältnis zu russland noch nicht so
geklärt ist wie das vielleicht sich
viele wünschen würden
also ich glaube alle
entschuldigung kanzler der besonnen
agiert und das ist ein attribut was ihr
ja heute auch in dieser sendung und wie
ich finde auch erstmal zu recht
zugesprochen bekommt aber besonnen heißt
natürlich auch man muss genau wissen was
man will sonst ist man auch nicht
besonnen und ich hatte den eindruck bei
seiner rede über die zeitenwende im
bundestag jetzt hat einer eine klare
vorstellung davon wie es weitergeht er
hat klare ziele und er hat ja auch zu
recht für diese rede
breiten bei sal wer durch die
gesellschaft bekommen durch märz für die
opposition in den wichtigen punkten die
zusage gegeben und ich dachte in dieser
großen krise in der regel sind ist das
erst mal die richtige aufstellung
und seitdem habe ich aber immer mehr
zweifel darüber ob
olaf scholz
sozusagen klar weiß was eigentlich sein
hauptziel in dieser krise ist und damit
kommt dann auch das führungsproblem in
etwas schwierigkeiten weil es nur heißt
der ich benenne ziele
überzeugte die ziele und dann gehen die
menschen mit und man muss es schon auf
den punkt bringen ist das hauptziel es
darf keinen atomkrieg geben sowie der
spiegel das lange gespräch was er mit
olaf scholz die für zeit überschrieben
hat als interessent als wörtliches zitat
also hauptziel des darf keinen atomkrieg
geben oder ist es das hauptziel der
angriffskrieg russlands muss scheitern
meine position ist nur wenn der
angriffskrieg russlands scheitern sind
wir auch sicher dass es keine ausweitung
wird also aber die prioritäten sind dann
schon umgekehrt die hauptzielrichtung
ist weil wir auch erreichen wollen dass
der krieg sich nicht ausweitet muss
putin in der ukraine scheitern wenn er
das gefühl hat er hat mit seinen
überfall erfolgt dann macht er weiter
darauf deuten alle schriftlichen
äußerungen von ihm hin darauf deutet hin
was ja von einer neuen weltordnung sagt
jetzt sind danach ttc
herford tel wir haben dann haben wir
sagen die putin benutzt die angst vor
einem atomkrieg als hebel um uns
davon abzuhalten die ukraine so zu
unterstützen die wir das etwa mit
waffenlieferung tun wir sind keine
kriegspartei die nachfrage noch mehr
verklärt sie wird auch keine
kriegspartei sie geht nicht mit eigenen
truppen in diesem krieg das war von
anfang an klar haben die amerikaner von
anfang an gesagt die nato alles gesagt
die ukraine weiß das auch aber wir
sollten unsere bevölkerung sagen das
wäre jetzt mein wunsch auch an den
bundeskanzler
dass das dass wir alles dafür tun müssen
in diesem rahmen den ich gerade
geschildert habe das gute in diesen
angriff nicht gelingt das ist das ziel
und nur wenn wir das erreichen sind wir
auch die sorge vor einem großen krieg
irgendwann der sich dann eskalierend
ergeben würde los herr von alle meine
antwort er von führungs jahr
ganz kurz war es jetzt auch ruprecht
polenz gerade angesprochen hat war es so
klug von olaf scholz dieses narrativ
eines der gefahr eines atomkriegs zu
bedienen um gegen massive unterstützung
der ukraine mit schweren waffen zu
argumentieren was er bis vor kurzem
gemacht hat und hat er damit nicht auch
das narrativ von von putin bedient der
natürlich mit dieser drohung versucht
tatsächlich nicht nur den westen zu
spalten sondern eben den westen auch
dazu zu bringen die ukraine nicht zu
unterstützen
also obwohl tier mit möglichen waffen
gedroht hat darüber kann man ja wirklich
streiten denn er hat das eigentlich nur
als defensive
definiert trotzdem ist natürlich ein
verbrecherischer mensch der einen krieg
angefangen hat ich glaube nur dass diese
ganze diskussion an dieser stelle an der
sache vorbei gehen kriege entstehen
nicht durch einen einmaligen schritt an
irgendeiner stelle auch dieser krieg in
der ukraine
hat eben viele quellen gehabt unter
anderem eben auch die quelle das auf
russischer seite auf jeden fall das
gefühl bestanden hat uns hat man mal was
versprochen nämlich die nato nicht zu
erweitern was gorbatschow noch mal
übrigens 2009 10 in seinem letzten buch
wiederholt und dieses verbrechen dieses
versprechen ist gebrochen wurden das
rechtfertigt nicht die invasion der
ukraine die sie konnte das wirkt das
wirklich das wirkliche problem für die
zukunft besteht darin dass wie kissinger
sagt und wie allison sagt und wie kluge
leute auch zb paul kennedy in seinem
buch über
den enkel german and also über das
aufsteigen england und deutschland vor
dem ersten weltkrieg solche großen
kriege entstehen nicht durch eine
einzelne entscheidung sondern sie
entstehen durch viele einzel-
entscheidungen die am ende wie ein teich
zu frieren und wo man dann sozusagen das
wasser nicht mehr flüssig halten kann
und deswegen ist das wirkliche problem
das wir an allen stellen dafür sorgen
müssen dass wenn irgendmöglich
friedenspolitik im vordergrund steht und
das gilt natürlich auch heute und wenn
ich für die spd etwas in anspruch nehmen
darf dann ist es das für uns krieg immer
sozusagen eine notlösung in der
verteidigung war aber niemals ein
sozusagen ziel damit etwas zu erreichen
und deswegen ist unsere friedenspolitik
in der vergangenheit bis heute aus
meiner sicht verteidigungs würdig und
deswegen bin ich auch bis heute der
meinung dass wir auch jetzt das gespräch
mit russland nicht abbrechen lassen
dürfen wir dürfen auch nicht an der oper
in st gallen schreibt kowski ausschalten
lassen weil er doch ein russischer
komponist ist lauter solchen unsinn
müssen wir vermeiden wir müssen
versuchen das gespräch auch jenseits von
putin zu erwarten putin wird auch nicht
für immer da sein russland kann auch von
den usa nicht aus der landkarte genommen
werden es bleibt eine große geografische
gegenüber seite von europa und nicht von
den usa gut einverstanden mit der
diskriminierung von von tschaikowsky
aber was wenn das ist kurz aufnehmen mit
wem spricht man eigentlich ist
tatsächlich putin noch der
gesprächspartner in russland auch nach
diesem krieg also ich hab bin jetzt gar
nicht ganz sicher ob ich es richtig
verstanden habe dass davon die rede war
dass russland von der landkarte genommen
wird weil ich glaube wenn es hier gerade
darum geht ein land von der landkarte zu
nehmen dann ist die ukraine ich darf
noch daran erinnern dass im vergangenen
sommer putin einmal eine rede gehalten
hat die auch verschriftlicht es wohl
sein ganzes weltbild seine ganze
letztlich
größenwahn sehr deutlich gemacht hat war
sagte die russin die belarussen und die
kleinen russen also die ukraine sind
eigentlich ein folgt die alle
zusammengehören hat er die ganze
ideologie schon sehr deutlich dargelegt
dir dann sehr konsequent um setz hat ich
glaube da gibt es nicht viel dran zu
deuteln zu der nato vorgeschichte habe
ich vorhin schon was gesagt ich finde
aber ihre frage interessant zur zur
positionierung von olaf scholz zu den
atomwaffen weil in der tat man sich da
zwei fragen stellt die eine ist
in der ganzen frage der sanktionen war
immer die position des westens wir sagen
nicht ganz genau was wir machen um
russland in der schwebe der ambiguität
zu halten sich genau zu wissen worauf er
sich einstellen kann indem man ganz klar
sagt wir werden nichts tun was die
grenze zum kriegseintritt überschreitet
die ja wohl gemerkt nirgends irgendwo
definiert ist also es gibt überhaupt
kein gesetz wo das drinstehen wurde und
selbst wenn es eines gäbe wäre völlig
unklar ob putin das respektieren würde
also im zweifel würde es nicht tun
sondern der definiert völlig und wir
wissen überhaupt nicht nach welchen
kriterien wann er etwas als
kriegseintritt bewertet und war nicht
und wenn er eine atombombe ehrlich
gesagt werfen möchte dann macht er das
und wenn nicht dann nicht wir müssen
glaube ich endlich mal aufhören zu
glauben dass wir putin einen vorwand
liefern müssen für irgendetwas der tut
was er will ist ein diktator der glaube
ich mehrfach in den vergangenen jahren
und jahrzehnten belegt hat wozu er fähig
ist wenn wir also von vornherein sagen
wir werden auf gar keinen fall in diesen
krieg eintreten weil wir so eine angst
vor atomwaffen haben wiegen wie russland
in einer sicherheit was ich taktisch
tatsächlich mich nachvollziehen kann die
andere frage und das betrifft wieder
unsere osteuropäischen nachbarn ist die
frage diese angst vor dem atomkrieg
besteht ja auch dann weiter wenn zum
beispiel das baltikum angegriffen wird
das ist ja die größte angst der balten
wenn ein bisschen geknabbert wird an
deren grenzen wenn ich das so sagen darf
wenn dort einmarschiert wird wenn dort
entweder ein paar grüne männchen kommen
was wir aus dem sonntags kennen oder ein
anderer weise dann haben wir immer noch
genauso viel angst vorm atomkrieg hey
was heißt das dann für artikel 5 des
nato vertrages heißt das dann dass wir
dann auch nichts tun damit ist er wäre
ehrlich gesagt das komplette westliche
verteidigungsbündnis nicht mehr das
papier wert auf dem es steht also das
sind alles fragen die sich die sich
daraus anschließend deshalb halte ich
habe ich diese äußerung von olaf scholz
zu den atomwaffen für unklug erhalten
wie im artikel 5 des nato vertrags steht
ja auch hin dass jedes land ist dann
gibt's wahrlich beistandsverpflichtung
aber jedes land entscheidet selbst auf
welche weise ist bei steht also auch das
wäre ja eine position jetzt berichten
bei ihm noch mal 1000 der frage wie man
mit putin in der zukunft umgehen sollte
sollte man noch den eindruck erwecken
dass er nach wie vor ein
verhandlungspartner sein kann kann man
nach einem solchen krieg nach einer nach
einem solchen völkerrechtswidrigen krieg
der ja
richtung völkermord auch geht kann man
mit jemanden wie putin noch verhandeln
ich meine jetzt nicht
waffenstillstandsverhandlungen sondern
tatsächlich auch noch eine neue
friedensordnung aufstellen
die schwierigkeit vor der die
bundesregierung gerade steht und das hat
auch frau werbung heute ja auch noch mal
im bundestag
erläutert ist man weiß ja gar nicht in
welchem stadium sich herr putin gerade
befindet also wenn man sich
totalitarismusforschung anguckt oder die
wege von von von despoten das ist ja
kein besonders überraschender weg den er
eingeschrieben hat er geht im prinzip
nahezu lehrbuchmäßig vor über die über
die jahre und jahrzehnte bis hin zu der
ausschaltung der der opposition und der
presse wenn es aber wirklich gefährlich
wird ist in dem augenblick in dem man
dies bot sich quasi
für unersetzlich und
land vaterland volk und seine führung
quasi zu einem erklärt zu einem
verschmilzt in seinem kopf weil das ist
dann ein punkt in dem irgendwann auch
ein disput sich gegen sein eigenes volk
richten kann dass er dann für zu schwach
und gerade bei dem phänomen putin dass
er sehr stark auf auf männlichkeit auf
potenz auf auch die vergewaltigungs
rhetorik gegenüber der ukraine
das sind ja alles dinge wo man wirklich
sagen muss
vorsicht ist berechtigt ich kann mich im
augenblick nicht hineinversetzen ich
sehe die bilder die wir alle sehen das
macht auf mich einen guten eindruck also
weder physisch noch psychisch was ich da
sehe und die überschätzung von putin ist
ja auch eine seiner
seltsame phänomene die ihn ja zum teil
auch in deutschland entgegen gestellt
als ist das heißt im moment halte ich
wirklich für sehr sehr wichtig dass auch
olaf scholz
durchaus auch klar macht welche
konsequenzen
stattfinden können oder scholz war vor
wenigen wochen noch bei ihm putin hat
ihm ins gesicht gelogen wie vielen
anderen auch und insofern halte ich es
für richtig auch von den bundeskanzler
zu sagen was auf dem spiel steht wir
müssen an der wir sind am ende der
sendung herr polenz sie haben den
letzten satz noch eine frage sollte man
mit putin auch nach dem krieg weiter
verhandeln ist ja noch ansprechpartner
wenn sie das in einem satz kurz
abzubilden man kann keiner traut man
kann kein vertrauen haben aber natürlich
gibt es möglichkeiten durch
vorleistungen
schritt für schritt weiter zu kommen ich
kann mir im moment nicht vorstellen wie
dann verhandlungen zur beendigung des
krieges die abgeklärt werden müssen
statt zehnten zu putin und dem russland
was er vertritt kann man ein vertrauen
nicht haben deshalb gilt letzter satz
wir müssen in zukunft davon ausgehen
dass wir den frieden in europa nicht
mehr so als gemeinsam frieden mit
russland sondern als schweden gegen
russland sichern müssen gegen russland
frieden gegen russland dass wir beim
nächsten mal an ich bedanke mich bei
helene borowski bei brach frank stauss
bei klaus von dohnanyi und bei ruprecht
polenz liebe zuschauer morgen in der
phoenix runde waffen für die ukraine
kann dass putin stoppen morgen im
bundestag ja ein gemeinsamer entschluss
von ampel koalition und opposition
schwere waffen in die ukraine zu liefern
und auch verstärkt waffenlieferungen zu
beschließen jetzt folgt für nicht der
tag mit thomas bade thema unter anderem
darin die frühjahrsprojektion der
bundesregierung es geht um die
wirtschaftliche entwicklung im land mit
dem bundeswirtschaftsminister robert
habeck und die gefahr einer drohenden
rezession bleiben sie bei uns